-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whew! Sorry.
I'm a little winded.
I'm almost halfway through
blowing up the balloons
for the Thanksgiving Day Parade.
And they got Snoopy, they got
Bluey, they got Oppenheimer.
They got a lot of...
Well, guys, everyone
is talking about this.
Today in San Francisco,
President Biden
met face-to-face with
Chinese President Xi Jinping
for the first time in a year.
Yeah, Biden said,
"Thank you for being here.
And President Xi was like,
"Thanks to TikTok,
I'm always here."
Well, guys, the House
passed a spending bill
to avoid a government shutdown,
and today, it was working
its way through the Senate,
and certain senators actually
spoke up about the bill.
Check out what they had
to say earlier today.
First up,
Senator Mitch McConnell said...
Then Senator Cory Booker said...
And Senator Chuck Schumer
said...
And Senator Joe Manchin said...
And Senator Tom Carper said...
And Senator Cynthia Lummis
said...
So Senator Chuck Grassley
Then Senator
Ben Ray Luján said...
Debbie Stabenow said...
Then Senator
John Fetterman said...
So, finally,
Mitch McConnell said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
-"Uncle Fester?"
Switching gears,
after Target announced
that it was going to start
locking up certain items
to prevent theft,
their C.E.O. said customers
are happy with the company and
are saying a big "thank you."
That story again.
The C.E.O. of Target
doesn't get sarcasm.
-Yeah.
-[ Sarcastically ]
Oh, thank you so much.
No, thank you.
I like having
everything locked up.
It's fun watching a guy
try 150 different keys
just so he can buy Q-tips.
Thank you.
He was like, "Yeah,
and so many of them telling me
to go thank myself, too."
-Oh, wow!
-Did you guys see this?
Google just unveiled a new A.I.
weather-forecasting program
that's more accurate
than existing models.
But it won't be ready to replace
your local weatherman
until it can accidentally
draw dirty shapes on the map.
That's the -- Then you know --
Then you know they got it, yeah.
"We're just in a little --
Yeah."
"We're expecting some moisture."
[ Audience groans ]
Rain, rain. Rain, rain.
-It's getting nuts out there.
-It is just nuts out there.
I don't know.
Well, according to this poll,
it's --
-Eeh!
-Well, I saw that YouTube is now
requiring creators to disclose
when they use A.I.
in their videos.
Did you read that?
-Oh!
-Yeah.
It makes sense for YouTube,
because A.I. has a lot
of people freaked out.
I mean, people are like...
-[ Screams ]
-I mean, there's so much
we don't know about A.I.,
and some people think
it has the potential
to bring the whole Internet
crashing down, kind of like...
[ Laughter ]
-Happens all the time.
-And for a lot of us, it feels
like A.I. hit us out of nowhere,
kind of like...
-Bye!
-[ Screams ]
-Some people want rules
put in place,
because if one small thing
goes wrong now,
a lot more can go wrong later,
kind of like...
♪♪
But other people think
that we should just go for it
and jump off the deep end,
kind of like...
-♪ Sail ♪
[ Laughter ]
Regardless, everyone wants to
know when something is
real or fake, because nobody
likes being tricked,
kind of like...
♪♪
Ah!
Alright. Should have seen
that one coming, yeah.
Some TV news.
CBS just announced
that, after seven seasons,
"Young Sheldon" is ending.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Yeah. They knew it was time
when Young Sheldon
was like, "Bazinga!"
Hey, I read about a new study
that said consuming alcohol
and caffeine together
could actually lead
to a better night's sleep.
-Whoa, whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-It's a phenomenon
that scientists call a coma.
Now whenever I see
a guy chugging
Red bull and vodka, I think,
"Well, there's a healthy guy."
"Friggin' Jack LaLanne
over there.
Bazinga!"
Hey, guys, I heard about a plane
flying out of New York City --
this is real -- that had to turn
around shortly after takeoff
because a horse
got loose on board.
See? This is exactly
why I always check my horse.
-Yeah.
Even worse,
when the horse sat down,
it took off its hooves.
-Really?
-Yeah.
It's one of those horses.
Finally, it's only Wednesday,
but it feels like so much
has already happened this week,
and I just want everyone
to remember that every story
has a moral, even news stories.
And sometimes, two stories
can have the same moral.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"The Moral of the Stories."
-♪ It's the moral ♪
♪ Of the stories ♪
-Let's take a look
at a couple of stories.
Story number 1...
You see what I'm saying?
-I see.
-Let's try another example.
Story number 1...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You see?
Here's another example.
Story 1...
-What?!
-It's wine-o'clock somewhere.
-Oh, my God!
Where's Old Sheldon?
-Next up, story 1...
-Oh!
-You see what I'm saying?
-Lessons.
Lessons to be learned, yes.
-Next up, Story 1...
-Aesop over there.
-Chickity-check yourself --
-Yeah, before you
rickety-rickety wreck yourself.
-Exactly.
And, finally, story 1...
There you have it.